here now with his take on all of this
and of course 33 days away from election
day we call him the great one Mark Levin
life liberty Levin the number one show
Fox News on weekends is nationally
syndicated radio show and dear friend of
mine great one how am I thank me God
bless us
well you sound pretty good I'll tell you
I'll give you my take on this Washington
Post piece
the question is why would they put it
out now I think Pam has a very good
theory I have a different Theory
and my theory is this is old news they
could have indicted Hunter a long time
ago they're protecting Joe of course
because they're not getting into any of
the bobolinsky laptop information which
is ripe for the taking
Joe Biden is a Manchurian putative
president in my view he's bought and
paid for not just by the Communist
Regime but others
that said I'll tell you what I think is
going on here this leak
is numerous sources
for some reason they mentioned Donald
Trump twice was absolutely nothing to do
with this matter
I think what they're trying to do is lay
a predicate lay a foundation not a legal
predicate but a foundation for the
American people and particularly
conservatives that go on well why don't
they indict them why don't they indict
Hunter it's black and white they've got
the goods on them
so then we can have people say okay fine
and then we have Merrick Garland say you
see I believe in equality under the law
so
we did XYZ 100 Biden and now we're doing
XYZ to Donald Trump I think this is a
complete setup
I think uh Hunter Biden is Small
Potatoes
I think they're protecting Joe Biden who
obviously is more important he's the
president of the United States and they
have absolutely no interest in him and
by the way neither do the media they
keep writing books about Donald Trump
like Maggie Haberman and others who
cares
what about Joe Biden and all of his ties
but I want to talk about this election a
little bit too and I want the public to
understand that the United States
the United States isn't guaranteed to
exist as
the United States in perpetuity
countries are subject to demise
Athens didn't want you know fell Rome
fell the British Empire exists no longer
we're a country that is falling we are a
country that is
facing demise as the number one
superpower on the face of the Earth it's
not because we voted for this it's not
because we want it because this is what
the Democrat Party wants and is doing
this is a man-made grave assault on our
Liberty on our prosperity and our number
one status as a superpower step by step
by step in every respect look at
education used to be
first there were no equals now education
is failing horribly the borders wide
open that is a an affirmative decision
by this Administration
massive government redistribution of
wealth from the private sector to the
phony masterminds in Washington that's
an obvious decision by the Democrat
Party the uh the destruction of energy
Independence this is an obvious decision
by the Democrat Party
soft on crime big on criminals obvious
decision by the Democrat Party
everything that's going on in this
country isn't by mistake it isn't
because of Mother Nature it is because
of the Democrats the Democrats hate this
country they don't believe in this
country they're embracing more and more
aggressive aspects of Marxism they
oppose an independent Judiciary they
threaten justices they want to pack the
court for the second time in a hundred
years they want to get rid of the
filibuster because they want to ram
through their agenda even if they only
have 50 Democrat Senators you go on and
on and on how they want to destroy our
voting system
and now they want non-citizens to have
the right to vote in various cities the
country's coming apart the country is
coming apart at the seams our customs
our Traditions are under attack our
history is under attack and there's one
political party
that serves as the political force for
all these radical and extreme ideas and
it's the same political party a hundred
years ago that stood for segregation
it's the same political party a hundred
years ago that refused to support
anti-lynching bills I'm telling it like
it is it's the same political party a
hundred years ago that supported
Eugenics it's the same political party
that demands abortion on demand that
rejects morality and ethics that is
teaching our little kids all kinds of of
grotesque behavior that is teaching our
little kids how to be racists and
victims that is teaching our little kids
to hate the country to hate capitalism
not just our little kids but our older
kids in colleges and universities where
there is no academic freedom there is no
free speech we have segregated areas now
we have no Jew areas now this country is
out of control now if you wanted to
continue to fall
you'll vote for the Democrats I don't
love all the Republicans as a matter of
fact I'm not a special pleader for the
Republican party but this time around
that's all we've got we have got to
fight this this movement this Democrat
Party it's not about some policy changes
ladies and gentlemen I just want to read
to you what Ronald Reagan said
freedom is never more than one
generation away from Extinction we
didn't pass it to our children in the
bloodstream it must be fought for
protected and handed for them to do the
same or one day we will spend our Sunset
years telling our children and our
children's children what it was once
like in the United States where men were
free Ronald Reagan thought Joe Biden was
a [ __ ]
and he didn't like him and he didn't
like the way he treated people in a very
nasty way when he was chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee Joe Biden is
a figurehead for Radicals that have been
appointed throughout this Administration
Obama types and all the rest we're
losing our country we have to start
clawing it back in November that's it
33 days the great one Mark Levin life
liberty live in Sunday nights 8 P.M
right here on Fox thank you sir